it was very important to us that you
were seeing various representations of
what it is to be a woman in lessons in
chemistry there's so many examples on
screen but then you also have it behind
the camera as
well and action it's been so incredible
to walk onto these sets where I have
seen so many women and producers and
directors to have that understanding and
to move forward together in this very
daring way and exposing our truths it's
intensely wonderful it's nice to have
anyone tell this story but it brings a
little bit more when it's someone who
may have experienced similar things in
their own career sweetheart I could use
another cup of joe when you're done with
that most women on production can
understand trying to claw their way into
getting taken seriously so to have our
directors who are all women commanding a
set it was really cool to see you're
going to be right here to go boom I'm a
black female director in a very male
oriented industry so I understood that
battle of saying this is what I want to
do this is what I love why can't I do it
why is it different for me we have rules
Mrs Z who do you think you are a woman
when I started there were very few women
around me you just kind of realized
early on that in order to get there you
really have to be fierce but at the same
time be more gentle because if you're
not gentle as a woman then you're
considered a how would you
describe the host stuck up unpleasant
didn't smile
once there's a beauty to Elizabeth salt
but also a grittin to her and we all can
relate to that I's pants why is she
wearing pants whether it's costumes or
production design or props you're
getting that experience in every layer
of it knowing that like two or three
women or two or three people of color in
each department makes it easier on this
project I really felt heard and trusted
one ready to go for her to pull and then
maybe she cuts into that's brilliant
courney yeah if you are the most capable
at doing something you should get the
opportunity to do it and Excel at it
period why would anyone discriminate
based on something as intellectually
non- determinative as gender
Calvin how many female scientists can
you name Madam
cury exactly if you're going to do this
this industry or actually any industry
take up space take up space the best way
you know how don't diminish yourself or
others you have a PL platform what you
say matters the best piece of advice
that I ever got was from a fellow
filmmaker who told me to just do you and
that changed my whole perspective as a
director let me just see how you would
do it Pour it in and then put it back on
the flame tilting it slightly and then
it should just go up in
Flames having women behind the camera
it's just amazing to watch and then I
know it's going to empower some little
girl I didn't know that it was possible
for me to work in a camera department
and so for me to see these women stand
up and be like hey I want to bring the
camera over here or hey I like this time
of shot is super inspiring it's a really
powerful feeling to know that we're all
here because we want to bring Excellence
to this because we know the story
deserves it and that we're capable of
bringing it at the end of our time here
together we will have done something
worth
doing and it will
[Music]
matter